NARRATOR: The following content
is provided under a
Creative Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or to view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Hi.
Today we start the part of our
course that in the old days in
the traditional treatment
began the
engineering form of calculus.
In other words, what we have
done is we have defined the
derivative, the instantaneous
change, as being a limit of an
average rate of change.
We spent a great deal of
time proving certain
theorems about limits.
Now what we're going to do is to
analytically take the limit
definition of a derivative,
which we have already done
qualitatively, apply our limit
theorems to of this, and
develop certain formulas for
computing derivatives much
more quickly from a
computational point of view
than having to resort to the
original definition.
In other words, what we're going
to do is to go from a
qualitative approach to the
derivative to a more
quantitative approach.
And for this reason, I just
call this lecture the
'Derivatives of Some Simple
Functions' to create sort of a
mood over here.
Now, the idea is this.
Let's go back to our
basic definition.
The derivative of 'f of x' when
'x' is equal to 'x1', 'f
prime of x1', on is by
definition the limit as 'delta
x' approaches 0, ''f of 'x1
plus delta x'' minus 'f of
x1'' over 'delta x'.
In other words, the average
rate of change of 'f of x'
with respect to 'x' as we move
from 'x1' to some new position
'x1 + delta x', taking
the limit as 'delta
x' approaches 0.
Now, just to illustrate this,
let's take, for example, 'f of
x' equals 'x cubed'.
In this case, if we now compute
'f of 'x1 plus delta
x'' minus 'f of x1', recall
that 'f' is the
function that does what?
Given any input, the output is
the cube of the input, so 'f
of 'x1 plus delta x' will be the
cube of ''x1 plus delta x'
minus 'f of x1''.
That's minus 'x1 cubed'.
We now use the binomial
theorem.
In other words, notice again
how mathematics works.
You introduce a new definition,
but then all of
the old prerequisite mathematics
comes back to be
used as a tool over here.
We use the binomial theorem.
The 'x1 cubed' term here
cancels with the
'x1 cubed' term here.
And what we're left with is
what? ''3x1 squared' times
'delta x'' plus '3x1
'delta x' squared''
plus 'delta x' cubed'.
And to emphasize the next step
that we're going to make,
let's factor out a 'delta x'.
Now, going back to our basic
definition, we must take this
expression and divide
it by 'delta x'.
The key idea here is that in the
last step, we're going to
take the limit as 'delta
x' approaches 0.
The limit as 'delta x'
approaches 0 means, in
particular, that 'delta x' is
not allowed to equal 0.
And as long as 'delta x' is not
0, the 'delta x' in the
denominator cancels the 'delta
x' in the numerator to leave
'3x1 squared' plus '3x1 'delta
x'' plus 'delta x squared'.
And now finally to find what 'f
prime of x1' is, we simply
take this limit as 'delta
x' approaches 0.
And notice what you're doing
over here when you let 'delta
x' approach 0.
We're going to be using
the limit theorems.
Namely, the limit of a sum
is the sum of the limits.
The limit of a product is the
product of the limits.
We can then take each of these
limits term by term.
Notice that the first term, not
depending on 'delta x',
it's limit is just
'3x1 squared'.
Each of the remaining terms
have a factor of
'delta x' in them.
As 'delta x' goes to 0 then,
each of the remaining terms go
to 0, and we wind up with, by
our basic definition, that 'f
prime of x1' is '3x1 squared'.
In particular, since 'x1'
could have been any real
number here, what we
have shown is what?
That if 'f of x' is equal to 'x
cubed', then 'f prime of x'
is '3x squared'.
And the important point here
is simply to observe that
we've got this result by
applying the basic definition
to a specifically
given function.
To generalize this result, let
'f of x' be 'x' to the 'n',
where 'n' is any positive
whole number.
And I want to emphasize that
because you're going to see as
this proof goes on that I really
use the fact then 'n'
is a positive whole number,
and I'll emphasize to you
where I do this.
I'm going to mimic the same
thing I did in the special
case in our first example
when we simply chose
'n' to equal 3.
Namely, I compute 'f
of 'x1 plus delta
x'' minus 'f of x1'.
Since the output is the n-th
power of the input, that's
just 'x1 plus delta x' to the
'n' minus 'x1' to the 'n'.
Now, as long as 'n' is a
positive whole number, we can
expand it by the binomial
theorem.
The first term will be 'x
sub 1' to the n-th.
That will cancel this 'x
The next term will be 'n 'x sub
1'' to the 'n - 1' power
times 'delta x'.
And now I do something
that's a little
bit cheating, I guess.
What I do next is I observe that
every remaining term in
the binomial theorem expansion
here has a factor of at least
'delta x squared' in it.
So rather than compute all of
these terms individually,
recognizing that I'm going to
let 'delta x' eventually
approach 0, I factor out a
'delta x squared' and say,
lookit, the remaining terms
have the form 'delta x
squared' times some
finite number.
I don't know what it is, but
it's some finite number.
I'll put that-- well, let's just
take a look and see what
that means.
In particular now, if I take
this expression and divide
through by 'delta x', we're
assuming again that 'delta x'
is not 0 because we're going to
take the limit as 'delta x'
approaches 0.
And remember our big harangue
about that.
When we approach the limit, we
are never allowed to equal it.
'Delta x' never equals 0.
Consequently, I can cancel a
'delta x' from the denominator
with a 'delta x' from
the numerator.
Canceling a 'delta x' from the
numerator knocks a 'delta x'
altogether out of this term
and leaves me with just a
single factor of 'delta
x' in this term.
What I now do is, referring to
my basic definition, I now
take the limit as 'delta
x' approaches 0.
As 'delta x' approaches 0, this
term, not depending on
'delta x', remains 'nx'
to the 'n - 1'.
And here's the key step.
The limit of a product is the
product of the limits.
This approaches 0.
This is some number.
And 0 times some number is 0.
And therefore, all that's left
here is 'nx1' to the 'n - 1'.
Again, since this was any 'x',
what we have is what?
If 'f of x' is 'x to the
n', where 'n' is a
positive whole number.
And where do I use that fact?
I use that fact to use
the binomial theorem.
Then the derivative is
'nx' to the 'n - 1'.
In other words, if you want to
memorize a shortcut now that
we know the answer, observe that
it seems to differentiate
'x' to the 'n'.
All you do is bring the exponent
down and replace it
by one less.
But for heaven's sakes, don't
look at that as being a proof.
Rather, we gave the proof,
then observed what the
shortcut recipe was.
Don't say isn't it easier just
to bring the exponent down and
replace it by one less instead
of going through this whole
long harangue over here?
No, this is how we prove
that result.
In other words, what we have
now shown is that to
differentiate 'x' to the 'n' for
any positive integer 'n',
the derivative is just
'nx' to the 'n - 1'.
So far, we do not know if
that result is true
for any other numbers.
We'll talk about that a
little bit more later.
Well, so much for
that example.
Let's look at another one.
Let's suppose that we have two
functions 'f' and 'g', which
are differentiable, say,
at some number 'x1'.
That means, among other things,
that 'f prime of x1'
and 'g prime of x1' exist.
Now define a new function
'h' to be the sum of
the given two functions.
By the way, we have to be
very, very careful here.
In general, 'f' and 'g' could
have different domains.
Notice that 'x' has to belong to
both the domain of 'f' and
the domain of 'g' for
this to make sense.
Consequently, I write down over
here that 'x' belongs to
the domain of 'f' intersect
domain 'g'.
In other words, it belongs to
both sets, the domain of 'f'
and the domain of 'g'.
Because if 'x' didn't belong to
at least one of these two,
this expression wouldn't
even make sense.
In other words, 'x' must be a
permissible input to both the
'f' and 'g' machines.
Now, what my claim is, is that
in this particular case, 'h
prime' exists.
In other words, 'h' is also
differentiable, and it's
obtained by adding the sum
of these two derivatives.
In other words, this is the
result that's commonly known
as the derivative of a sum is
the sum of the derivatives,
which, of course, sounds like
it should be right.
But I'll comment on that
in a moment also.
what.
I want to show is simply this,
that 'h prime of x1' is simply
'f prime of x1' plus 'g
prime of x1', OK?
And my main purpose is to
highlight the basic
definition.
That's what I want to give
you the drill on.
Namely, how do we compute
'h prime of x1'?
We must look at ''h of 'x1 plus
delta x'' minus 'h of
x1'' over 'delta x', then take
the limit as 'delta x'
approaches 0.
That's the basic definition
that will be used over and
over and over.
At any rate, sparing you all
of the details here, let's
simply observe what?
That 'h of 'x1 plus delta x'',
since 'h' is the sum of 'f'
and 'g', is 'f of 'x1 plus
delta x'' plus 'g of
'x1 plus delta x''.
Consequently, 'h of 'x1 plus
delta x'' minus 'h of x1' is
'f of 'x1 plus delta x'' plus
'g of 'x1 plus delta x''--
that's this part--
minus ''f of x1' plus
'g of x1''.
Now, the idea is I want to
divide this by 'delta x'.
I also have some knowledge of
the differentiability of 'f'
and 'g' separately, so I would
like to combine or regroup
these terms to highlight
that fact for me.
So what I do is I group these
two terms together, these two
terms together, and then divide
through by 'delta x'.
In other words, ''h of 'x1 plus
delta x'' minus 'h of x''
over 'delta x' is what?
''f of 'x1 plus delta x'' minus
'f of x1'' over 'delta
x' plus ''g of 'x1 plus
delta x'' minus 'g of
x1'' over 'delta x'.
Now, for my last step, I simply
must take the limit as
'delta x' goes to 0.
Well, just look at this
bracketed expression.
The limit of a sum is the
sum of the limits.
So to take the limit of this
expression, I take the limit
of these two terms separately
and add them.
By definition, the limit of the
bracketed expressions as
'delta x' goes to 0--
by definition--
is 'f prime of x1'.
And as 'delta x' goes to 0,
this term here becomes 'g
prime of x1'.
And by the way, for the last
time, let me give you this
word of caution again.
Do not make the mistake of
saying, gee, when 'delta x'
goes to 0, my numerator is 0.
Therefore, the fraction
must be 0.
No!
When 'delta x' goes to 0, sure,
if you replace 'delta x'
by 0, the numerator is 0, but
so is the denominator.
In other words, this is our old
story that the derivative
becomes a study of 0/0 so if
you let 'delta x' equals 0.
In other words, the whole
point is what?
That as 'delta x' approaches
0, this by definition is 'f
prime of x1'.
This by definition is
'g prime of x1'.
And therefore, we have proven
as a theorem 'h prime of x1'
is 'f prime of x1' plus 'g
prime of x1', that the
derivative of a sum is the
sum of the derivatives.
Now, the main trouble so far is
that every result that I've
proven rigorously for you, you
have probably guessed in
advance that it was
going to happen.
You say who needs this rigorous
stuff when we could
have got the same result
by intuition.
And this is where the rift
between the way the pure
mathematician often teaches
calculus and the way, say, the
applied man teaches calculus
often comes in.
The point is that the places
that you can get into trouble
often aren't stressed
soon enough.
So before we go any further, let
me show you that you must
be careful, that up until now,
we have been very fortunate
when we say things like the
limit of a product is the
product of the limits, fortunate
in the sense that
they worked out the way the
wording seemed to indicate.
Let me give you an example of
what I mean by saying beware
of self-evident.
I claim, for example, that the
derivative of a product is not
the product of the derivatives
necessarily.
And the best way to prove that
to you is not to say take my
word for it.
This is one of the beauties of
computational mathematics.
You can always show by means of
an example what's going on.
For example, let 'f of
x' be 'x + 1', let 'g
of x' be 'x - 1'.
Now, the derivative of
'x + 1' is simply 1.
The derivative of 'x
- 1' is also 1.
Namely, we differentiate
this as a sum.
The derivative of 'x' is 1.
The derivative of
a constant is 0.
In other words, 'f prime of x'
is 1, 'g prime of x' is 1.
On the other hand, if we first
multiply 'f' and 'g', 'x + 1'
times 'x - 1' is 'x squared
- 1', and the
derivative of that is what?
Well, to differentiate 'x
squared', we just saw.
Bring the exponent down.
Replace it by one less.
That's '2x'.
The derivative of
minus 1 is 0.
In other words, if you multiply
first and then take
the derivative, you get '2x'.
On the other hand, if you
differentiate first and then
take the product, you get 2.
Now, it is not true that '2x'
is a synonym for 1 for all
values of 'x'.
In other words, if you
differentiate first and then
take the product, you get a
different answer than if you
multiply first and then
differentiate.
In other words, self-evident
or not, the thing
happens to be false.
In fact, let's see how the
theory helps us in this case.
See, what I've shown you
here is that this
result isn't true.
Oh, I should say that this
result is true, that the
equality isn't true.
What I haven't shown you
is what is true.
And again, to emphasize
our basic definition,
let's do that now.
Let's show how we can use our
basic definition to find the
correct result.
What we do is we let 'h of x'
equal 'f of x' times 'g of x'.
And we're going to use the
same structure as before.
We are going to compute 'h of
'x1 plus delta x'', subtract
'h of x1' divide by 'delta x',
and take the limit as 'delta
x' approaches 0.
We do that every time.
All that changes is the property
of the particular
function that we're
dealing with.
In any event, if I do this, 'h
of 'x1 plus delta x'' is
obtained by replacing 'x' in
here by 'x1 plus delta x'.
And 'h of x1' is obtained by
replacing 'x' by 'x1' over
here, so I wind up with 'f of
'x1 plus delta x'' times 'g of
'x1 plus delta x'' minus 'f
of x1' times 'g of x1'.
And now the problem is I would
like somehow to be able to get
terms involving 'f of 'x1 plus
delta x'' minus 'f of x1', 'g
of 'x1 plus delta x'' minus 'g
of x1', and I use the same
trick here that I used when I
proved that the limit of a
product is the product
of the limits.
Namely, I am going to add in
and subtract the same term,
and this will help me factor.
In other words, what I'm going
to do here is this.
I write down this term.
Now I say to myself I would like
an 'f of x1' term to go
with the 'f of 'x1
plus delta x''.
So what I do is I write
minus 'f of x1'.
Then I observe that 'g of 'x1
plus delta x'' is a factor
here, so I put that
in over here.
See, 'g of 'x1 plus delta x''.
See, in other words, I can now
factor out a 'g of 'x1 plus
delta x'' from these two terms
and have the formula that I
want left over.
But, of course, this term
doesn't belong here.
I just added it myself, or I
should say subtracted it, so
now I put it in with the
opposite sign, namely, plus 'f
of x1' 'g of 'x1
plus delta x''.
And now put this term back
in here: minus 'f of
x1' times 'g of x1'.
In other words, all I've done
is rewritten this, but by
adding and subtracting the same
term, which does what?
Dividing through by 'delta x',
I factor out a 'g of 'x1 plus
delta x' from these two terms.
That leaves me with ''f of 'x1
plus delta x'' minus 'f of x1'
over 'delta x'' because I'm
dividing through by 'delta x'.
Now, what I do is I factor out
'f of x1' from here and divide
what's left through by 'delta
x'-- that gives me 'f of x1'--
times the quantity ''g of 'x1
plus delta x'' minus 'g of
x1'' over 'delta x'.
I get this thing over here.
Now, my final step is what?
I take the limit as 'delta
x' approaches 0.
Well, let's do the
easy part first.
As 'delta x' approaches 0, this
becomes 'f prime of x1'.
And as 'delta x' approaches 0,
this becomes 'g prime of x1'.
This, of course, remains
'f of x1'.
And I guess you would argue
intuitively that as 'delta x'
approaches 0, 'x1 plus delta
x' approaches 'x1'.
Therefore, 'g of 'x1
plus delta x''
approaches 'g of x1'.
That would give you this
result over here.
I have put a little asterisk
over here because I want to
make a footnote about this.
You know, even though you would
have allowed me to say
that this approaches 'g of x1'
as 'delta x' approaches 0, it
is not in general true that we
can be this sloppy about this.
I want to mention that later,
but meanwhile, I don't want to
obscure the result that
I'm driving at.
Namely, assuming that this is
a proper step, what we have
shown now is that to
differentiate a product, you
differentiate the
first factor and
multiply that by the second.
Then add on to that the first
factor times the derivative of
the second.
Now, that may not be
self-evident, but what we have
shown is that self-evident or
not, this result follows
inescapably from our basic
definitions and
our previous theorems.
And by the way, to finish off
the example that we started
where 'f of x' was 'x + 1' and
'g of x' was 'x - 1', notice
that if we use this recipe,
'f prime of x1' is 1.
'g of x1' is 'x1 - 1'.
'f of x1' is 'x1 + 1'.
'g prime of x1' is 1.
And if we now combine all of
these terms, we get twice
'x1', and that's exactly what
the derivative of the product
should have been.
In other words, just to
summarize this thing off,
notice that when we were back
over here, this was the result
that we were supposed to get.
In other words, to differentiate
a product, our
basic formula tells us that
it's the first times the
derivative of the second plus
the second times the
derivative of the first.
And let me just go back to this
parenthetical footnote
that I wanted to mention
for you.
It is not always that the
limit of 'g of t' as 't'
approaches 'a' is 'g of a'.
Remember, our whole study of
limits said you cannot replace
't' by 'a' or 'a' by
't' automatically.
In fact what, type of examples
did we see that this got us
into trouble?
For example, let 'g of t'
be ''t squared - 1'
over 't - 1'', OK?
Then the limit of 'g of t' as
't' approaches 1, well, as
long as 't' is not 1,
't - 1' is not 0.
We can cancel the 't - 1' from
the numerator and the
denominator.
That leaves us with 't + 1'.
As 't' approaches 1, 't
+ 1' approaches 2.
In other words, the limit of 'g
of t' as 't' approaches 1
is 2, but 'g of 1' doesn't
even exist.
'g of 1' is 0/0.
In other words, it's not true
here that as 't' approaches 1,
'g of t' approaches 'g of 1'.
In other words, you can say
that when 'x1' approaches
'x2', 'f of x1' approaches
is 'f of x2'.
It doesn't have to be true.
Why then could I use it in
my particular example?
And by the way, the situation in
which the limit of 'g of t'
as 't' approaches 'a' is 'g of
a' comes under the heading of
a subject called continuity, and
that is a later lecture in
this particular block.
We'll talk about it in
more detail then.
But for the time being, let me
show you why we could use this
in our present case.
Again, we use a trick.
We want to show that as 'x1 plus
delta x' gets close to
'x1', 'g of 'x1 plus delta x''
gets close to 'g of x1'.
And to do that, that's the
same as showing that this
difference gets close to 0 as
'delta x' gets close to 0.
What we do is utilize
the fact, and
this is very important.
We utilize the fact that
'g' is differentiable.
And what we do is-- and it
doesn't look like a very
significant step, but it is.
What we do is we take this
expression and both multiply
it and divide it by 'delta x'.
I don't know if you can see the
method to my madness here.
The whole thing I'm setting up
here is that when I do this,
the bracketed expression now
looks like the thing that
yields 'g prime of x1' when
you take the limit.
And now that's exactly
what I'm going to do.
I'm going to take the limit of
this expression as 'delta x'
approaches 0.
The limit of a product is the
product of the limits.
As 'delta x' is allowed to
approach 0, this bracketed
expression by definition becomes
'g prime of x1'.
And obviously, this is just
the limit of 'delta x' as
'delta x' approaches
0, which is 0.
The fact that 'g' is
differentiable means that this
is a finite number, and any
finite number times 0 is 0.
In other words, the fact that
'g' was differentiable tells
us that this limit is 0, and
that's the same as saying that
the limit 'g of 'x1 plus delta
x'' as 'delta x' approaches 0
is, in fact, 'g of x1'.
As self-evident as it seems,
this is not a true result if
the function 'g' is not
differentiable, or it may not
be a true result if 'g'
is not differentiable.
Well, so much for that.
There is one more recipe that's
very important called
the quotient rule.
The one we just did was called
the product rule, how do you
differentiate the product
of two functions.
There is an analogous type of
recipe for differentiating the
quotient of two functions.
And since the proof is very
much the same as what I've
already done, I leave
the details to you.
They're in the textbook.
You can go through that in
more detail if you wish.
But the result is this.
If 'f' and 'g' are
differentiable functions, the
quotient is also
differentiable.
And the way you get the result--
and again, notice how
nonintuitive this is.
Get this in terms of logic
if you're trying
to memorize it logically.
You take the denominator
times the
derivative of the numerator.
And you subtract off the
numerator times the derivative
of the denominator.
And then you divide the whole
thing by the square of the
denominator.
See, again, notice how
overwhelming this course
becomes if you try to memorize
every result.
Rather, do what?
Memorize the basic definition
and derive these results.
And believe me, once you use
these results long enough,
you'll memorize them
automatically
just by repeated use.
Well, at any rate, let me give
you an example of using this.
Remember before we could only
differentiate 'x' to the n if
the exponent was positive?
Suppose 'f of x' is 'x' to the
'minus n' where 'n' is now a
positive integer.
That means 'minus
n' is negative.
How would we differentiate
this?
And the idea here is we say
lookit, if this had been a
positive 'n', we could
handle this.
But 'x' to the 'minus n'
by definition is 1
over 'x' to the 'n'.
We know how to differentiate 'x'
to the 'n' when 'n' is a
positive number.
What do I have now?
I have a quotient.
So I use the quotient rule.
'f prime of x' is what?
It's my denominator, which is
'x' to the 'n', times the
derivative of my numerator.
My numerator is a constant so
it's the derivative of 0,
minus the numerator--
that's minus 1--
times the derivative
of the denominator.
But for a positive integer
'n', we know that the
derivative of 'x' to the 'n'
is 'nx' to the 'n - 1', all
over the square of
the denominator.
But the square of 'x' to the
'n' is 'x' to the '2n'.
And if I now simplify
this, I have what?
This is 0.
This is 'minus n'.
This is 'x' to the 'n - 1'.
This comes upstairs
as a 'minus 2n'.
So I have 'minus x' to
the 'n - 1 - 2n'.
That's the same as what?
'Minus nx' to the
'minus 'n - 1'.
And by the way, this is a rather
interesting result now
that we've proven it.
Suppose we said to a person,
let's just bring down the
exponential and replace
it by one less.
Well, if we brought down the
exponent, that's 'minus n'.
And if we replaced 'minus n'
by one less, that would be
'minus 'n - 1'.
And lo and behold, that's
precisely the
result that we got.
In other words, by using the
quotient rule, for example, we
can now show that the rule
that says bring down the
exponent and replace it by one
less applies for all integers,
not just the positive
integers.
In later lectures, we will
show that it applies to
fractional exponents as well
as to any real number
exponents as we go along.
But I just wanted you to
see the structure here.
And in fact, I think in terms
of what this lesson is all
about, we have given
enough examples.
I think we might just as well
summarize here, and let it be,
and let the rest come from the
reading material and the
learning exercises in general.
And the summary is
simply this.
The basic definition of a
derivative is 'f prime of x1'
is the limit as 'delta x'
approaches 0, ''f of 'x1 plus
delta x'' minus 'f of
x1'' over 'delta x'.
That basic definition
never changes.
We always mean this when
we write this.
But what is important is that
this basic definition can be
manipulated to yield, and now
I use quotation marks
"convenient," because I don't
know how convenient something
has to be before it's
really convenient,
but convenient what?
Recipes.
Meaning what?
Convenient ways to find
the derivative.
You see, what's going to happen
in the remainder of our
course as we shall soon see in
the next lecture, in fact,
what we're going to start doing
is using derivatives the
same as they always were
intended to be used.
But now we are going to have
much sharper computational
techniques for finding these
derivatives more rapidly than
having to resort to the basic
limit definition.
Well, enough about
that for now.
Until next time, goodbye.
NARRATOR: Funding for the
publication of this video was
provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum Foundation.
Help OCW continue to provide
free and open access to MIT
courses by making a donation
at ocw.mit.edu/donate.